break down the uh the uh acronym I think  I got that right for [ __ ] that was  powerful yeah Utopia Supreme sacred and  yummy  I got the yummy  that's eat it all look don't be wasteful  that's great how like was that is this  something that you obviously came up  with this acronym yourself I didn't know  if this was like already out there or  something well I come up with acronyms  for everything that you know that can be  misinterpreted or  you know when you are always saying like  [ __ ] [ __ ] like I want people with a  woman to know when I say it is coming  from an empowering place like a  determine of endearment maybe it's a  positive thing it's a positive thing  right yeah I think like Tupac did that  with the n-word like he broke down Thug  Life well and and the n-word right yeah  never ignorant I can't even I'm not even  gonna say what it is because it's kind  of like I'm like halfway spelling it out  and I don't want people to put that on  me okay but with that being said